hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmc control
sc.l2-3.13.12 prohibit remote activation
of collaborative Computing devices and
provide indication of devices in use to
users present at the device
[Music]
say hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all this cmmc
dfars and nist SP 10171 compliance stuff
on top of an already colossal workload
well I've got great news for you you
found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's jump into
it here's the big question what on Earth
is a collaborative Computing device I
mean seriously what is that do you know
10 points if you do well it turns out
that what they're actually referring to
are items such as webcams and
microphones and I know interactive
whiteboards I'm not you know can't make
this stuff up uh that allow you to
collaborate with others so why they
couldn't just say that I have no idea
meanwhile the interesting thing is that
this functionality is essentially a
built-in functionality these devices
already perform the function via either
a small indicator light you know when
you turn your on your your webcam or
even your smartphone there's a little
indicator light a lot of times people
don't even notice that or they play a
tone uh when
um you know when the device turns on
like when we turn on a camera it'll play
a little tone when you hit the record
button so now the issue of not allowing
these devices to really activate may be
a different story personally I recommend
the the answer that these devices May
either be disconnected or disabled when
not in use another answer that works may
be that without multi-factor
authentication access to the machine
where these devices are hosted nothing
could be activated so there's sort of a
multi-factor authentication and a login
variable that would be mandated so they
really just can't be randomly activated
remotely so let's dive into what the
assessors are looking for on this one
three assessment points one determine if
collaborative Computing devices are
identified so are they identified uh
Implement they're identified in the
Baseline Network inventory configuration
again if you've done your due diligence
and you've done all the documentation
you're supposed to do on your network
that includes computer inventories and
Equipment inventories and things like
that you should be listing out webcams
microphones Etc in there if they're
external or included in the machine
itself second assessment Point determine
if collaborative Computing devices
provide indication to users of devices
in use implemented webcams phones all
have light and or sound indicators that
the device is in use assessment Point
number three determine if remote
activation of collaborative Computing
devices is prohibited implemented remote
activation collaborative Computing
devices is not possible without
authorization via multi-factor
authentication again that's just an
example the answer there's probably
better answers you could have but again
that's one that we put in here that'll
fit the bill also disabling webcams and
microphones when not in use is another
great way to solve for this control now
uh at on-call we work with defense
contractors just like you who have had
this D fars nist itar and cmmc
compliance stuff dropped in their laps
like a seagull on sunny day we teach you
how to level up and be a proper on-call
compliance hero for your company
eliminating gaps gray areas and getting
this solved all while showing you how to
leverage compliance is your secret
weapon to land more Defense work with
higher profit margins yes I promise it's
possible now that's what becoming an
on-call compliance hero can do for you
if you're looking for more help getting
compliant our compliance experts are
always on call for you visit
cmmccomplianceecrets.com or check out
the bio below for links to get help
right now I love the content we're
putting out here for you help us out
with a big thumbs up on that like button
or even better smash the Subscribe
button to get the latest compliance
content as soon as our compliance cards
roll it out it's a great way to make
sure you're in the loop as compliance
continues to evolve until the next
compliance tip my friends stay safe and
secure out there and drop your comments
below to let us know what you'd like to
know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance and
I'll see you on the next next one
[Music]